on this tuesday night
kovid 19 and class sizes in canada the
back to school nerves over new
setups they're not sure what they're
going to have to face with 30 kids in
the classroom
and in the u.s the sharp rise in kids
getting infected
skepticism as russia approves the
world's first coronavirus vaccine
right now it's almost a political
statement why scientists are shutting
down this shot
breaking news on the american
presidential election joe biden has just
named his running mate
and the new battle in combat sports we
need that physical contact this is how
we get better
the fight to be allowed to fight with
others again
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
bara nasser good evening and thank you
for joining us
four weeks to the start of school and
this year it's not the kids with the
stomach turning anxiety
it's the parents no matter where you are
in this country if you have children
it's likely a daily worry and a topic of
conversation
many experts have said school is needed
for a child's mental health
but some parents fear reopening could
risk their physical health
with an increase in covid19 cases
in canada 9 500 cases have been recorded
in children under the age of 19.
that accounts for 8.1 percent of total
covet 19 cases in our country
26 children in canada have been admitted
to the icu
one child a girl has died from the virus
there is no question how schools roll
out this unprecedented plan will impact
transmission rates among children and
adults
today british columbia officials
announced the start of the school year
is going to be delayed to allow
teachers administrators and staff to be
together
and to understand cdc guidelines before
the learning begins
heather your ex west now with some key
logistical questions about
getting back into the classroom this
classroom is part of a photo op from the
alberta ndp
but it illustrates the concerns of
parents across the country
my daughter's also very anxious the one
that's going into grade 7 simply because
they're not sure what they're going to
have to face with 30 kids in the
classroom
we maintain that physical distancing is
one of the key layers of protection
in a school context federal guidelines
have called for schools to reduce the
number of children using
one physical space at the same time but
as back to school plans emerge
few provinces have committed to reducing
class sizes
ontario is maintaining its pre-pandemic
rule
requiring the average class size within
a district be less than 25.
other provinces have opted to create
learning cohorts quebec bubbles are
capped at 25
it's 75 in manitoba 60 to 120 depending
on grade level in
bc nova scotia has only set a class size
limit for preschool children that's 15
while alberta and saskatchewan have no
class or cohort size limits in place
elsewhere countries with large class
sizes have seen the virus spread
quickly after schools reopened in israel
where some classes had up to
38 students hundreds of schools were
forced to shut down
after more than 900 people became sick a
stark contrast to a country like denmark
where classes of 20 were further divided
into smaller pods
after five weeks that country saw no
increase in culvert 19 spread
we keep the community numbers low the
risk to the school drops
exponentially the real problem is if
there is a high number of virus in the
community the likelihood of a child
bringing that into the school
unfortunately then goes up and once it's
in those tighter environments
it can spread quite rapidly which is
exactly why
so many parents are struggling with what
to do this fall
worried that sending one child back to a
crowded class
could put entire families at risk
heather eurix west global news
calgary many kids have already gone back
to school in the united states
and tonight there is some alarming new
data that shows coronavirus cases in
that country
have spiked among children recently the
report published by the american academy
of pediatrics
and children's hospital association
shows 97
000 kids were infected with covet 19
during the last two weeks of july
that's a surge of more than 40 percent
since the beginning of the pandemic more
than 330
000 children have tested positive across
49 states
making up nearly 9 of all cases in the
united states
experts here say it's highly unlikely
canada is going to suffer the same fate
because our community transmission is
much lower
but as jackson proskow reports parents
in the united states are wondering if
schools
are a safe place for their kids
just days into the new school year
students are already back out of the
classroom in parts of georgia
at least nine students tested positive
for covet 19
after pictures emerged of packed
hallways and few masks
hundreds are now quarantined you saw
they weren't socially distant
they did not have masks on and both boys
sat
in classes all day long parents in state
after state are wondering
is it worth the risk walking into the
school i didn't see a lot of mass
wearing
and i think that that should have been
something that was mandatory and not
optional
in kentucky the governor postponed plans
for in-person learning as cases surge
getting them back at the height of the
pandemic
i think would be irresponsible there's a
tiny it's a tiny fraction
of death tiny fraction
and they get better very quickly but
president donald trump keeps pushing
back
he's not a doctor but he insists that
children are practically immune
they don't catch it easily they don't
get very sick and according to
the people that i've spoken to they
don't transport
or transfer it to other people that's
simply not true
those younger groups play a role in
transmission more broadly i'm worried
that we're going to see disease spread
throughout the age range
especially with the pandemic still
raging
college sports may be the next casualty
of the virus
with parts of the football season
canceled or postponed
there's a lot of reasons to not play and
for the overall health and safety
it's i think it's important not to play
the number of daily new cases seems to
have stabilized for now
but at a rate far higher than in any
other country
more signs the virus is far from
contained in the united states
jackson prosco joins me now for some
major political breaking news
joe biden has finally revealed his
running mate after delays for the 2020
u.s presidential election and jackson
it's not surprising but it is a history
making choice
it is far the choice is senator kamala
harris of california and it's historic
because she is the first black woman
and the first woman of south asian
heritage to appear on a major party's
presidential ticket
she of course is an experienced
prosecutor in california she put those
skills to the test
against joe biden and famously sparred
with him during the first debate
but there are no hard feelings there if
anything that showed her skill as a
capable campaigner
for the fight against donald trump that
is to come and by
choosing her she is essentially boxed in
the trump campaign
which is currently trying to portray
democrats as being against the ideals of
law and order
tough to sell that when you've got a
former federal prosecutor on the ticket
farah harris and biden will make their
first joint appearance at a speech
tomorrow in delaware
all right and she has a canadian
connection she attended high school in
montreal thank you so much jackson
proskow in washington for us tonight
two political developments in our
country today the testimony from senior
government figures in the ongoing we
charity controversy continues
our abigail beeman is following the
latest developments from ottawa abigail
the minister of diversity inclusion and
youth was held to account for some of
her testimony at the finance committee
what happened far nearly a month ago
bardesh chagar testified at a different
committee
finance and told them she hadn't spoken
to we about the student grant program
it later emerged in a media report that
she had had a conversation with we
charity co-founder craig kielberger but
about a different proposal
chagger said she wanted to set the
record straight today the opposition
said she wasn't doing that at all
on december 10 2020 i appeared at we day
in ottawa
and the second time i interacted with we
charity
craig kielburger personally was over the
phone on april 17
2020 that phone call lasted just over
30 minutes and we were we spoke about an
unsolicited program in regards to youth
entrepreneurship
social entrepreneurship something
happened in that meeting minister chagar
and you didn't tell us at finance
tell us now just come clean i will not
be
told that i am not providing information
openly that's exactly what i'm doing the
committee
also heard from canada's top civil
servant ian shugart
neither shoeguard nor chagger could say
whether we has repaid the funds it was
given by the government for the now
canceled student program
we tells global news it has repaid 22
of 30 million dollars and is waiting on
the government to accept the rest
shugart also wasn't able to answer a
number of other questions
including whether he attended a key
briefing with the prime minister on may
8.
are you aware that they're not
registered to lobby
because they signed a contribution
agreement that said they follow the
lobbying act
i'm i'm not aware of those details i
don't know
at what point the focus shifted from
uh the the we charity to the we charity
foundation i do not know if it would be
the same
individuals responding on on the other
side to
both parts of the organization you don't
know for sure if you were at the meeting
i suspect that i was there for the
briefing
may 8th and may 22nd but
i i don't i don't want without being
certain to
to tell the committee definitively i
believe yes
you believe you're at the meeting i i
suspect that i was there but i've
if you want me to confirm with my
calendar then i will do that
okay abigail outside of the committee
questions are being raised about whether
finance minister bill morneau will be
able to keep
his job what's the latest there the
globe and mail reports mourinho's job is
in jeopardy after clashes with the prime
minister over the covet 19
economic response and that the prime
minister's office was caught off guard
by moreno's
41 thousand dollar repayment to we for
two family trips
this afternoon the pmo released a
statement saying trudeau has full
confidence
in mourinho farah okay abigail being in
ottawa thank you abigail
rcmp and alberta say a fatal attack on a
doctor in red deer was targeted
and pre-planned dr walter reynolds died
yesterday after being attacked while
working at a busy walk-in clinic
the 45-year-old is a father of two young
children
police have charged 54-year-old deng
maviour with first degree murder
assault with a weapon and assaulting a
police officer investigators say
he knew dr reynolds through the clinic
the vaccine that's not immune to
criticism
coming up why there are a lot of doubts
around
russia's inoculation against covet 19.
to the worldwide coronavirus case count
where it seems we're hitting troubling
new milestones almost daily
and today there's another globally cases
of kova 19 have now surpassed
20 million doubling in the past six
weeks alone
over a quarter of those cases are in the
united states with more than 5 million
but other countries are rising at
alarming rates
brazil now has over 3 million cases
there are more than 2 million in india
and russia is nearing the 1 million mark
and that country is the first to
announce it has developed and approved a
vaccine for kovid 19.
the world's scientific community is
skeptical but russia says it will go
forward with mass production within
weeks as eric sorensen reports the move
could represent
historic scientific success for the
russians or risk
millions of lives the symbolism is
inescapable
the country that produced sputnik the
world's first satellite in space
is calling this breakthrough sputnik v
the russian vaccine
to defeat covet 19 around the world
the announcement was made by russia's
president vladimir putin
flanked by online medical experts putin
vouching for its effectiveness
stating one of his two adult daughters
was inoculated
and she's fine
russia began testing its vaccine just
weeks ago it says more than 20 countries
have expressed interest in receiving
more than
one billion doses we'll be producing
vaccine with other countries
in true partnership and really making
vaccine available
to the world to countries who wanted the
countries who need it
russia has jumped ahead in the vaccine
race by seemingly skipping the wide
scale
phase iii trials other countries are
undertaking
and that worries medical experts it's
disappointing they skipped a lot of
steps
in terms of making sure that a vaccine
safe coming to the market
health experts say the long-term effects
are unknown and even a small problem
with the vaccine
could harm tens or hundreds of thousands
of people around the world
that's why other countries are taking
time to do proper trials
it's just surprising and skeptical
canadian public health officials
want to see the russian data that has
not yet been made public
to actually be able to get access to the
quote the russian data the evidence
the scientific information to to be able
to understand exactly what has happened
with respect to their trials and then to
be able to draw conclusions philippine
president rodrigo duterte has already
drawn conclusions
he says he trusts russia's president
putin and will be among the first to
acquire vaccines for his
country russia says it will partner to
manufacture the vaccine with five other
nations
global distribution to start in october
it does have a
political incentive to say that you were
the ones that got to the vaccine first
you were the ones that saved humanity
and got society back to normal
this fall could see the highest stakes
gamble yet in the covit 19 pandemic
millions who will risk trying a new
vaccine and millions of others who will
wait
and watch eric sorensen global news
toronto still had the mysterious twist
in belarus after a contentious election
sparks
violent protests
you're watching global national
[Music]
protesters and mourners gathered near
the epicenter of the catastrophic
explosion that devastated beirut
one week ago today more than 170 people
were killed
and at least 6 000 others were injured
the prime minister and cabinet resigned
yesterday
but outrage over corruption and
government dysfunction
remains strong lebanon's economy was in
peril long before a fire ignited
2750 tons of ammonium nitrate
stored at beirut's port there were fears
a growing hunger problem would be
exacerbated by the catastrophe
as the explosion destroyed grain silos
today the world food program promised to
send 50
000 tons of wheat flour to help restock
the country's supply
the former soviet republic of belarus is
also in the grips of a political crisis
the challenger in the country's highly
disputed election
svetlana takanawskaya has mysteriously
fled the country she says it's to
reunite with her children
but her supporters say she was forced
out
this comes after two nights of violent
protests in the streets of minsk
the government is cracking down and at
least one protester
has died in the unrest redmond shannon
now
on the upheaval in what's considered
europe's last
dictatorship
[Music]
[Applause]
this is how many belarusians have been
disputing sunday's election results
with thousands of them being placed
under arrest
and this is the woman they believe
should be their new president
on monday svetlana ticonovskaya called
on president alexander lukashenko to
step down
claiming his landslide win was a lie
hours later this was her reading a
statement calling on people to give up
protesting it appears to be filmed
inside the country's election commission
before she fled to lithuania
on tuesday the former english teacher
released this video where she called
herself
a weak woman she said it was her
decision to
leave to reunite with her children whom
she had sent to lithuania
during the campaign as far as i
understand maybe later will be more
clarifications but she had not
not so many options just to leave the
country
the european union says the elections
were neither free
nor fair but it may resist renewing
sanctions for fear of pushing belarus
closer to russia ticonovskaya had
stepped into the race
late after her blogger husband was
jailed and blocked from running
during the campaign belarusian security
forces also arrested
32 men they say were russian mercenaries
no one really understands why these
people are being detained
how they ended up right here right now
lukashenko has blamed foreign actors for
disrupting the country's internet this
week
and at the start of the covet 19
pandemic he suggested saunas and vodka
as a way to fight the virus i think the
primarily hope is that
people unite continue to protest and
that the degree of the violence
decreases
the future could hinge on the loyalty of
lukashenko security forces
faced with defending an ever more
unpopular dictator
redmond shannon global news london
negotiating knockouts next quebec spars
over combat sports
in a pandemic
combat athletes in quebec are fighting
for their right to train
sports like boxing karate or anything
else that involves sparring
is still banned due to the covet 19
pandemic
now sports federations and athletes are
urging provincial health officials
to let them get back into the ring
felicia perolo explains
like many athletes who practice combat
sports in quebec
celeste bayard jean is allowed to train
in the gym
on her own but any fighting or sparring
with an opponent
is off limits it's a big impact because
for sure we have to spar
to practice our boxing so like i can do
fitness and conditioning stuff but i
can't really improve my boxing skills
most team sports in the province have
already been given the green light to
resume and so
athletes who practice combat sports are
fighting to be allowed
to practice with contact again they're
like 20 players on a hockey team so
20 players times two they're 40 40 guys
or girls or
40 people just like playing on the same
field on the same ring
on tuesday morning quebec's combat
sports federations met with public
health officials
to propose the next phase of training
quebec's boxing federation president
ariane forte
says there's a way to practice contact
training
safely we think that the bubble of four
people training always with the same
training always together is actually
either the same level of risk of what is
allowed in other spheres of society and
other sports right now or even less
risks forte says she fears that if the
province doesn't allow
combat sports to resume contact soon
registrations for gyms and different
disciplines will dip
and the sports will struggle to survive
athletes agree that fighting
is a crucial part of what they do we
need that physical contact this is how
we get better this is how we work on our
that's how we work on our craft
this is how we become what we aspire to
be when we started boxing we need the
physical contact
[Applause]
the federations should get an answer
from public health officials
within a few days on whether the next
phase has been approved
and for these athletes that answer can't
come
soon enough
one more time felicia parilla global
news montreal
that's it for global national for this
tuesday i'm farah nasser thanks for
making us a part of your evening
tonight's your canada is the sun blazing
over the toronto skyline
if you'd like to share your canada with
us email your pictures to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching until tomorrow take
care of yourselves
and each other good night
[Music]
you